[Music]
in what should be my cousin news won't
you be my cousin
oh so mad about cat breath my cat bit
the [ __ ] out of my toe yesterday dude
what the hell's wrong with stupid-ass
cat Oh cute didn't think it was like a
little toy like he like I was hit it was
day one off my in my bed and just like
he's cute
you don't get scared no really
oh because of monsters yeah like though
you got me I'm not doing how to be brave
and I'm like you think I could catch a
girl fight dangle my dick off the bed
absolutely try I can't probably bite it
dude just be there with a blanket like
halfway out and I'm just be like you
should be you should be careful though
because you could just randomly catch
your uncle or something oh you never
know no don't do it during Thanksgiving
nice hey when I win a try it yeah
alright Tom Hanks found out he's related
to mr. Rogers after playing him in an
upcoming movie what the [ __ ]
what do you do 23andme I don't like mr.
Rogers why that's fun okay calmed me
down
me too I grew up on his ass nice person
dude he kind of creeped me out a little
bit
growing up you got a card again so
you're like watching Gras older men
change I think I was just like weirded
out a little bit by like how like soft
Eve now I love him but like all kind of
soft he was and he's like come on little
Danny
I was like whoa that's a little bit
weird but actor Tom Mix plays a great
one absolutely he's well I think they
should give Judge Judy a mr. Rogers ish
kids show oh never say I'm at her in
person she should be she that's on brand
yes it's just me that much she could
come to me night go [ __ ] yourself and
I've like hard off
yeah so Tom Hanks found out that he's
related in great casting yeah I'd love
some so this is a the family line here
on how like they're actually there's six
cousins so they share an ancestor that
was born in 1732 so ancestry.com found
this out and crazy
on the red carpet she found out and so
did his wife so here we go I want to
break some you see you tonight
our friends ancestry did some digging
you are related to your pulling our leg
table just weak that [ __ ] love him I
was oh you know like him yes Gina yes
few of my friends actually met him they
said that he's the dip he's really
shitty lame I don't know like I don't
remember the details of those two
heartbroken yeah I don't know they said
they work with him and they met him they
said he was a really [ __ ] person and
broke my heart really like he was having
a bad day or like this is a part of this
several times well like they rear-ended
him with their car and he who wasn't
cool about it I don't want to believe it
that's what they said I don't wanna
leave it her friend was like when I was
sucking his dick he was like really
[ __ ] me and calling me [ __ ] and [ __ ]
exactly when the I he paid me to suck
his dick he called me a [ __ ] so I still
don't to believe it but that's what they
said that's the first I've heard anyone
say it I'm like dude that's
heartbreaking
he was the only person I was scared when
that hold me to [ __ ] was happy
I want but everyone else wholesome most
innocent [ __ ] I was like please
not Bill Cosby please have Bill Cosby
now you see why I'm so jaded that Bill
Cosby it was like anybody anybody any
even the most innocent [ __ ] it
would break my heart if it was mr.
Rodgers like you imagined they went
through his house may sound like child
porn no I don't break my [ __ ] heart
but that would make good comedy though
I'm sorry dude you're up there I mean
here am I glad you're up there but Oh
beautiful man Gina shut up god damn what
do you mean you're not fees up there I
thought you were with kids I hope that
[Applause]
really just cool I bet you anything he
was thinking well I'm already related to
Abraham Lincoln's Oh what kind of
lineage does he come from this nepotism
that's when he's with you or does that
mean that white people is very incestual
southern plantation owner did you know
part of our brand
yes oh so he is related to Abraham
Lincoln through Lincoln's mother Nancy
and by the way he Tom Hanks did narrate
killing Lincoln which is a 2011 TV movie
about the president's assassination and
so she related to woody all these movies
is a part of his related 60th cousins
with woody his mom was a Barbie dolls
[Laughter]
but anyway so yeah like I said he has an
ancestor named Johannes Burt who was why
what have you done don't you wanna did
you hear his name Johanna's I was even
thinking that he left before the name
even happened okay okay
his mom's accessible to come yeah Tom
Hanks his mother were talking about okay
yeah yeah but it was Lincoln's mom okay
got it mom was a cesspool of come is
what you want your quote to be right
Mary Todd good old Mary Todd yeah former
first lady the United States and we
think her first service didn't like a
huge amount of people were related to
Genghis Khan ur like his gang get scum
is what I called him bro cuz he's been
in so many he's been spreading his come
all over the world that's true how do
you do it Joe how do you do it he raped
a lot of [ __ ] come over I put the ball
on the tee for the guy you're looking
it's not like he has a level of
pettiness that I've always wanted to
achieve in my life do you ever have like
someone pissed him off and he wiped out
their whole River town and like had his
people dig a river to redirect it to
read a record to wash the whole town
away he just deleted it from the bucket
he's also the one that killed his
brother right no idea that's how I
behave in the game The Sims I think he
killed his own blood brother
him and his brother gotta argue many
kill it might be they Fox about you oh
my god so there's this book right then I
was okay so I was reading this book
called the 48 laws of power and there's
this Robert Green yeah there's a woman
named they call her Empress whoo dude
this lady went from like nothing to
[ __ ] the king to become the Kings side
piece to making the Queen like a friend
of hers whatever to get her to be
friends with her and then Empress rule
got pregnant from the king right I still
had a baby and then like she called the
Queen like oh you know cut me the baby
or whatever and then while the Queen was
like kind of there she suffocated the
baby to make it look like the Queen
killed the baby
so they [ __ ] killed the Queen and
Bruce woo came into power and like rule
for like ten years straight peaceful
it's a car the first shady [ __ ]
yeah like shit's insane she was dope I
mean like deaf man that's why I love
history
yeah dude Cersei Lannister it's a
real-life drama kill my kids oh yeah
yeah yeah Stephen get more gangsters
yeah so you look up for Empress Wu she's
[ __ ] dope but I want that level of
pettiness it's not the baby killing
thing I was like you wanna what yeah or
like wiping towns out with the whole
river that shit's [ __ ] but you need to
be you need to have an ability to be
cutthroat which I think you have a very
big heart so you can't get there because
you're not willing to kill so how does
she become more cut though huh how does
she become woke up to stop caring about
okay people yeah what's wrong with you
Empress Wu wouldn't love you she
wouldn't she would pretend that she
loves you and then kill all your babies
so smart though dude it's genius though
like she could maybe while the Queen was
there to frame her dude um well she it
was like well obviously the Queen killed
the baby when she went to visit the the
concubine you know some people are like
is she spread that word and I'm saying
how do they find out that she killed the
baby
oh I don't know yeah I hope when she
ruled cuz he said she'd always work and
then she ruled for only ten years
probably died of dysentery right I'm
sure but I hope she lived large for
those ten and there's a there's a
there's a there's a myth or whatever or
something like there's a story behind
her that she was so [ __ ] powerful
about like woman power and all that [ __ ]
whenever warlords and whatever or anyone
that comes to meet her she makes him
kiss the Pearl the [ __ ] eater [ __ ]
[ __ ] power it's a kiss her like kiss
the Pearl before you [ __ ] like it and
instead of like kissing the ring you
kissed the Pearl I hope it's clean well
she is the Empress she might have bath
and Bodyworks of that time like Chinese
herbs and [ __ ] dude in some villages not
like mafia is still a practice in some
parts of the world to have like kids
suck the chieftain guy's dick is a sign
of respect or yeah Wow
but I don't think it's actually a sign
of respect I think that's just what they
tell the perverted yeah they just make
it up right yeah like this is a great
honor and it's like I don't know about
that
because in ancient Mesopotamia it was a
great honor for girls
I think firstborn girls or whatever to
go to the temple during harvest season
and become temple hookers and in every
one to get a good harvest they would go
to the temple and they would make
donations and they would [ __ ] the girls
and it was an honour for the girls to
get [ __ ] by the whole village is
insane yeah right but that's why I love
history
people are [ __ ] stupid and nuts and
they think that this was a time of the
old days but we're still still still
doing [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] it's just
normalized because we're just kind of
like delusional in the time that we're
in right now
what history book did you get that out
of the history of gameboard me about it
somewhere
[Music]